مساء الخير،
عند عودته إلى بغداد سنة 296 هجرية،
اندفع الحسين بن منصور الحلاج في شوارع المدينة،
يدعو الناس إلى الثورة على فساد عصره،
وهاجم الخلافة العباسية في عهد المقتدر بالله بكل مؤسساتها،
القصر والأحزاب والقادة العسكريين والحُجّاب،
الذين أسرفوا في المجون واستبدوا بالناس،
وحادوا عن قيم الإسلام.
عاصر الحسين بن منصور الحلاج الخليفة المقتدر بالله،
الذي ورث الحكم عن أخيه المكتفي بالله،
الذي توفي سنة 289 هجري،
وكان المقتدر بالله طفلا لم يتجاوز عمره 13 عاما،
كانت والدته التي تُدعى شغب هي التي تدير شؤون الحكم،
وشغب هذه، جارية تزوجها المعتضد بالله والد المقتدر بالله،
وهو خليفة مهووس بالجواري والغلمان،
يقال انه جمع في حريمه حوالي 4000 جارية.
شغب إسمها الحقيقي ناعم،
كانت شديدة الغيرة من بقية الجوارى في قصر الخلافة،
وبمساعدة خادمة لها تدعى ام موسى،
قامت بالتخلّص من بعضهن بتسميمهن،
وكانت كثيرة الهرج والمرج في القصر،
فسمّاها الخليفة المعتضد بشغب.
يقول المؤرخ ابن الأثير متحدثا عن الخليفة المقتدر بالله :
«كان المقتدر الطفل الخليفة،
لا هم له إلا أن يلهو في قصره،
بين عشرة آلاف خصي من الصقالبة والجواري والغلمان.
ومن فوق هذا الخليفة الطفل،
والدته السيدة شغب التي أحالت المُلك العريض إلى ألعوبة في يدها،
وبلغ من نفوذها واستهتارها،
أن أمرت قهرمانتها أم موسى أن تجلس في مجلس القضاء للمظالم،
ومن نفوذ هذه القهرمانة،
أنها كانت تُصدر أوامر الصادرات وإحصاء الأموال والتركات».
كان الحلاج  معارضا قاسيا وجسورا لكافة القوى المنتفعة بالخلافة،
لا يعرف المهادنة والتقيّة،
فهاجم الشيعة وطالب بعزلهم عن الخراج،
وإبعادهم عن بيت المال، لأنهم اختلسوا الأموال، واحتكروا الأرزاق.
وهاجم المعتزلة،
لأنهم تركوا دعوة الإصلاح وتشبّثوا بالجدل الفكري العقيم.
وهاجم الفقهاء لأنهم كانوا يبررون ظلم وجور الحكّام.
كان يردد بين الناس
انه؛ "لن يقبل الله عبادة عابد، تحت ظل حكم فاسد" ،
وكان يعتبر ان أولياء الله هم الذين يحملون أمانة الرسل،
وان واجبهم ان يستشهدوا أو ينتصروا.
الحلاج لم يكن مجرّد درويش شاطح في أسواق بغداد،
بل كان زعيما ثائرا وكان هدفه هو إقامة خلافة ربانية،
يقودها القطب الولي الأكبر،
الذي سيقود العالم الإسلامي والإنسانية كلها إلى معارج الكمال القرآني،
ليكون الإنسان جديرا بخلافة الله على الأرض.
انتشرت دعوة الحلاج في كافة ارجاء الخلافة العباسية،
فسمي في الهند بالمُغيث،
وفي الصين وتركستان بالمُقيت،
وفي فارس بابي عبد الله الزاهد،
وفي خرسان بالمميّز وبحلاج الأسرار،
وفي البصرة بالمجير،
وفي بغداد بالمصطلم.
يقول لوي ماسنيون:
«وأدار الحلاج دعوته من وراء الحجب،
وفي سنة 296 هجري الموافق ل908 ميلادي،
انفجرت المؤامرة الإصلاحية وقامت تحت رعاية الحلاج،
تولاها ابن المعتز وهو ابن عم الخليفة المقتدر،
ولكنها استمرت يوما واحدا ثم فشلت،
فأعيدت الخلافة إلى المقتدر،
بمساعدة الشرطة، وابن الفرات، الذي تولى الوزارة،
وكان أول امر أصدره هو القبض على الحلاج وأتباعه.
ونجا الحلاج من القبض عليه،
واختفى لدى الحنابلة، ببلدة  سوس من الأهواز،
وبعد ثلاث سنوات من اختفائه،
وبخيانة عامل مدينة واسط ،حامد بن العباس، قُبض على الحلاج وجيء به إلى بغداد."
احتفظوا جيدا باسم عامل واسط حامد بن العباس،
فهذه الشخصية مركزية في حياة ومصير الحلاج.
عند وصول الحلاج إلى بغداد سجينا،
سيضطر الخليفة المقتدر إلى اصدار امر بالعفو عنه خوفا من تمرّد انصاره.
وفي هذه الفترة سوف تزداد شعبية الحلاج،
وسيمتدّ نفوذه إلى داخل قصر الخلافة،
وسيجد المساندة من ام الخليفة السيدة شغب.
أصبح للحلاج مكانة عالية في قصر المقتدر بالله،
وله وزراء يدعمون أفكاره ويأتمرون بأمره،
من أهمهم الحسين بن حمدان، وابن عيسى، وحاجب الخليفة نصر القشوري،
وعائلة القُنّائي التي كانت لها مناصب هامة في دواوين الخلافة العبّاسية.
هذا الإفتتان بشخصية الحلاج،
عند العامة في أسواق بغداد والخاصة في محيط الخليفة المقتدر بالله،
سوف يجلب له عداوة الوزير،
وعامل مدينة واسط سابقا الذي سلّمه للمقتدر، حامد بن العباس،
الذي حلّ محلّ الوزير بن الفرات سنة 306 هجري.
يقول المستشرق الإنجليزي رينولد نيكلسون؛
" لقد ضاق كبار رجال الدولة بنفوذ الحلاج وصيحاته وشعبيته الحارّة،
التي تهدد بثورة تطيح بهم وبنفوذهم".
إذن وضع الوزير الأكبر حامد بن العبّاس خطة للتخلّص من الحلاج،
والسبيل إلى ذلك هو دق اسفين بينه وبين عامة الناس،
التي افتتنت به وذلك باتهامه بالزندقة والمروق عن الدين،
فاستنجد بالفقيه الظاهري محمد بن داود،
الذي كان قاضيا في محكمة القضاء الكبرى في بغداد وكان يمقت الحلاّج،
فرفع أمر الحسين بن منصور الحلاج إلى المحكمة العليا،
وطالب بقتله بتهمة ادعاء الألوهية.
إذن الخطة تقتضي محاربة الحلاج باسم الدين،
وتحطيم صورته دفاعا عن المقدّس الروحي للناس الذين أحبّوه.
ربما قد نتساءل؛ لماذا وُجّهت تهمة ادعاء الألوهية للحلاج؟
الحسين بن منصور الحلاج كان يردد في لحظاته الوجدية،
في أسواق بغداد تقرّبا من ربّه، ما يلي؛
أَنا مَن أَهوى وَمَن أَهوى أَنا
نَحنُ روحانِ حَلَنا بَدَنا
فَإِذا أَبصَرتَني أَبصَرتَهُ
وَإِذا أَبصَرتَهُ أَبصَرتَنا
أَيُّها السائِلُ عَن قِصَّتِنا
لَو تَرانا لَم تُفَرِّق بَينَنا
روحُهُ رُوحي وَرُوحي روحُهُ
مَن رَأى رُوحَينِ حَلَّت بَدَنا...
وكان يردد كذلك؛
يا نَسيمَ الريح قولي لِلرَشا
لَم يَزِدني الوِردُ إلاّ عَطشا
لي حَبيبٌ حُبُّهُ وَسطَ الحَشا
إِن يَشَأ يَمشي عَلى خَدّي مَشى
روحُهُ رُوحي وَرُوحي روحُهُ
إِن يَشَأ شِئتُ وَإِن شِئتُ يَشا...
استمعوا إلى هذه الكلمات الجميلة للحلاج،
بصوت الفنان المبدع احمد حويلي،
وبالمناسبة نتمنى الشفاء العاجل للفنان احمد حويلي،
استمعوا إليه فصوته وكلمات الحلاج ترياق للروح...
أَنا مَن أَهوى وَمَن أَهوى أَنا
نَحنُ روحانِ حَلَنا بَدَنا
فَإِذا أَبصَرتَني
أَبصَرتَهُ
وَإِذا أَبصَرتَهُ
أَبصَرتَنا
يا نَسيمَ الروح
قولي لِلرَشا
لَم يَزِدني الوِردُ إلاّ عَطشا
لي حَبيبٌ
حُبُّهُ وَسطَ الحَشا
إِن يَشَأ يَمشي عَلى خَدّي عَلى خَدّي مَشى
روحُهُ رُوحي
وَرُوحي روحُهُ
إِن يَشَأ شِئتُ وَإِن شِئتُ يَشا
لا يمكن فهم المذهب الحلاجي،
دون فهم مفهومين رئيسيين في فكره الصوفي،
وهما مفهوما الحبّ الإلهي ومقام الفناء في ذات الله.
الصوفي في تجربته الروحية يسافر عبر الحب الإلاهي،
من ملكوت الأرض إلى ملكوت السماء.
ويتدرّج في المقامات من المقام الأول وهو مقام التوبة،
إلى المقام الأعلى وهو مقام الفناء بالله.
عند الصوفية الطريق إلى الله رحلة فردية وهو بعدد أنفاس الخلائق.
ويعود الفضل للحسين بن منصور الحلاج،
في التأصيل الفكري والذوقي لمفهوم الحب الإلاهي،
الذي تأسس مع رابعة العدوية،
ليصبح مفهوما مركزيا في التصوّف،
التصوّف سيتحول نهائيا مع الحلاج من الزهد إلى المحبّة.
من بعده سيقول صاحب كتاب الفتوحات المكية محيي الدين بن عربي؛
"إلهي ، ما أحببتك وحدي ، لكن أحببتك وحدك."
وسيقول جلال الدين الرومي احد أقطاب التصوف،
الذين ساروا على خطى الحلاج معرّفا الحب الإلهي:
هو الكحل الذى تكتحل به عين القلب فينجلى بصرها،
ويقول كذلك؛
حين تذهب إلى الله مكسور الجناحين تعود محلقا في السماء.
الإمام الغزالي، حجة الإسلام، في كتابه مشكاة الأنوار،
الذي خصص فيه فصلا كاملا للدفاع عن الحلاج،
يتحدث عن رحلة العارفين إلى سماء الحقيقة فيقول؛
"العــارفــون بعـد العــروج إلــى سمــــاء الحقيقــة،
اتفقــوا على أنهم لم يروا في الوجـود إلا الـواحـد الحـق،
ولكـن منهـم مـن كـــان لـه هــذه الحــالـة عرفـانا،
ومنهم مـن صـار لـه ذوقـا وحـالا،
وانتفت عنهم الكثـرة بالكليـة واستغرقـــوا فـي الفردانية المحضـة،
فلـم يبـق عنـدهـــم إلا الله،
فسَكِروا سكرا وقع دونه سلطـان عقولهـم،
فقال بعضهم: أنا الحق،
وقال الأخــر: سبحاني ما أعظم شأني،
وقـال الآخر: مـا فـي الجبة إلا الله،
وكـلام العشاق في حال السكر يُطوى ولا يُحكى."
ربّما خطيئة الحلاج انه لم يطو وجده وعشقه لله،
كما قال الإمام الغزالي،
بل كشف عن خلوته في الحضرة الإلاهية.
لذلك قال القطب الصوفي عبد القادر الجيلاني؛
"عَثَرَ الحلاج ولم يكن في زمانه من يأخذ بيده ء ولو أدركْتُهُ لأخذْتُ بيده".
سنة 301 هجري ستقام المحاكمة الأولى للحلاج في دار القضاء العالي،
وسيجنّد لها الوزير بن العباس رجلا مغمورا من الصوفية،
ويلقّنه ان يقول أمام المحكمة،
انه سمع الحلاج يقول في مسجد المنصور ببغداد "أنا الحق"،
وجيء برجل آخر قيل انه من اتباع الحلاج،
وقال أن الحلاج اله وانه يُحيي الموتى.
واجه الحلاج الشهود بكل شجاعة،
يقول ابن كثير انه "أنكر ما نُسب اليه وقال :
أعوذ بالله ان ادعي الربوبية، أو النبوّة،
وإنّما أنا رجل أعبد الله،
وأكثر له الصوم والصلاة وفعل الخير، ولا أعرف غير ذلك..."
في هذه اللحظة،
انتصر احد اعضاء هيئة المحكمة وهو القاضي الشافعي ابن سُريج للحلاج وقال؛
"إن مثل هذا لا يدخل في القضاء، والأدلّة غير ثابتة والدليل لا يوجد. "
وبذلك فشلت المؤامرة الأولى ضد الحلاج.
الوزير حامد بن العبّاس الذي فشل مخططه لن يبق مكتوف الأيدي،
بل سيأمر بتشكيل هيئة قضائية جديدة،
برئاسة القاضي ابي عمر محمد بن يوسف بن يعقوب،
وكمساعد له القاضي ابو جعفر بن البهلول بن حسان التنوخي،
لمحاكمة الحلاج مرّة أخرى،
وأمر بزيادة  تهم جديدة للحلاج،
منها ادعاءه النبوّة وانه يُحيي الموتى،
ويُسخّر الجن، وانه ساحر،
وجيء بشهود ضدّه في دار القضاء العالي.
أنكر الحلاج مرّة أخرى أمام المحكمة ما نُسب اليه،
وردد قائلا؛
"أنا عبد الله، أؤمن به وبرسله، وادعو إلى الحق،
وأنشد خير المسلمين، ولا أُقر الظلم، ولا أعرف هؤلاء الشهود..."
وتحت هتافات الناس المتجمهرة  خارج دار القضاء والمساندة للحلاج،
اضطر القضاة إلى الإقرار بأنه لا وجود لتهمة ثابتة ضد الحلاج توجب قتله،
واعلموا الوزير حامد باستحالة إدانة الحلاج،
فجن جنونه،
واستنجد بالخلفية المقتدر،
طالبا منه الإبقاء على الحلاج في السجن أو تحديد إقامته حفظا لماء الوجه،
واستجاب الخليفة لطلبه،
واصدر أمرا يقضي بتحديد إقامة الحلاج،
بين سجن دار الخلافة ومنزل الحاجب نصر القشوري.
أراد الخليفة المقتدر ووزيره بن العباس،
ان يظل الحلاج تحت المراقبة،
في ظرف تشهد فيه الخلافة العباسية اضطرابات خطيرة،
من أهمها ثورة القرامطة في شرقي الجزيرة العربية،
والتمرد الفاطمي في شمال افريقيا،
والذي سيعلن قيام الخلافة الفاطمية وعاصمتها مدينة المهدية بتونس.
الحلاج خلال فترة سجنه واقامته الجبرية،
والتي دامت ثماني سنوات وسبعة أشهر وثمانية أيام،
سوف يؤلّف اهم كتاب له وهو كتاب الطواسين،
والذي ضمّن فيه أمّهات أفكاره،
وهو الأثر الوحيد الذي وصلنا من مؤلفات الحلاج،
بفضل صديقه الوفي الحنبلي ابن عطاء.
نعم قد تبدو علاقة الحلاج بالحنابلة غريبة،
لأن أكثر من كفّر وشيطن الحسين بن منصور الحلاج
منذ أكثر من ألف عام هم السلفيون، اتباع احمد بن حنبل،
مستندين إلى فتوى لابن تيمية تقول؛
"أن من اعتقد ما يعتقده الحلّاج من المقالات التي قتل الحلّاج عليها،
فهو كافر مرتدّ باتفاق المسلمين؛
فإنَّ المسلمين إنَّما قتلوه على الحلول والاتحاد،
ونحو ذلك من مقالات أهل الزندقة والإلحاد،
كقوله: أنا الله، وقوله: إله في السماء وإله في الأرض".
ابن تيميّة، مجموعة فتاوى المجلد 2، ص 480.
في حين ان الحلاج كان صوفيا سنيا،
وحاضنته السياسية وقتئذ كانت الحنابلة،
في سجنه بدار الخلافة كان الحاجب نصر القشوري يسمح له بالخروج ليلا،
فكان يذهب للتهجد والتضرّع عند قبر الإمام أحمد بن حنبل طوال الليل.
ابن كثير في البداية والنهاية،
وهو من المؤرخين الذين لا يتعاطفون مع الحلاج، يقول؛
«واستطاع الحلَّاج وهو بسجنه في دار السلطان أن يستغوي جماعةً من غلمان السلطان،
وموَّه عليهم واستمالهم بضروبٍ من حيله،
حتى صاروا يحمونه، ويدفعون عنه،
ويرفهونه، ويُدخلون عليه من شاء.»
استمعوا،
إلى ما يردده إلى اليوم شيوخ السلفية حول الحسين بن منصور الحلاج...
وهذا الزنديق الحلاج،
كان يقول أيضا باللاهوت والناسوت،
وهذا السر  في إعجاب المستشرقين به،
ودعوتهم إليه، وتلميعهم إياه، والعياذ بالله،
لذلك حتى نفسه، يقول عن نفسه أنا الله،
كيف أنا الله؟
أي إن الله حال فيه كما يقول،
وهذا كفر ما بعده كفر،
أعجب من مسلم كيف يلمّع هذه الشخصية،
كيف يعجب به، كيف يُلبّس عليه فيه وهذه اقواله!!!
ليتخلصوا من هذا الدين الى الإلحاد والزندقة،
كان يعتقد عقيدة التناسخ،
هذه عقيدة أيضا ماجوسية وهندوسية،
أن الإنسان إذا مات روحه تنتقل إلى مخلوق آخر.
البلاء الذي اكتسبه هذا الرجل من الهند،
تعلم السحر ومعلوم إن السحر كفر بالله عزّ وجلّ.
فهذا الرجل كان يتعلّم السحر،
وبرع فيه وادهش كثيرا من الناس،
وقُتِل، هذا قُتل بسبب أقواله واعتقاده.
المستشرقون الذين يريدون إفساد دين الإسلام،
يعجبهم من يوافقهم في دينهم واعتقاداتهم،
فبين الحين والآخر الى عصرنا هذا،
يحرسون على دعم كل ما ينسب إلى الإسلام وهو ليس من الإسلام.
الحلاج ملحد،
الحلاج ملحد، وقُتل في الإلحاد،
نعوذ بالله
ولا بجوز انه يُمدح،
لا يجوز انه يُمدح ويثنى عليه
وهو معروف بالضلال و الإلحاد والزندقة.
الحلاج الذي أُتهم بادعاء النبوة،
سوف يكتب في سجنه اجمل وابلغ ما قيل في نبي الإسلام محمد،
يقول في كتاب الطواسين،
وبالتحديد في طاسين السراج متحدّثا عن الرسول ؛
"همته سبقت الهمم،
وجوده سبق العدم،
واسمه سبق القلم،
لأنه كان قبل الأمم،
رفع الغمام، أشار إلى البيت الحرام،
هو التمام، هو الهُمام ،
هو الذي أمر بكسر الأصنام،
الذي أُرسل إلى الأنام، والأجرام،
فوقه غمامة برقت،
وتحته برقة لمعت،
أشرقت، وأمطرت، وأثمرت.
العلوم كلها قطرة من بحره،
الحِكم كلها غُرفة من نهره،
الأزمان كلها ساعة من دهره،
الحق به ، وبه الحقيقة،
هو الأول في الوصلة، هو الآخر في النبوة".
إذن قائل مثل هذا الكلام،
كفّره من يُلقّب بشيخ الإسلام ابن تيمية،
ولازال إلى اليوم اتباع بن تيمية يكفرونه.
سنة 308 هجري سوف يعزّز الوزير حامد بن العباس نفوذه داخل قصر الخلافة،
بتحالفه مع قائد الجيش مؤنس التركي،
الملقب بالخادم الأكبر،
والذي اكتسب حظوة كبيرة لدى الخليفة المقتدر،
بعد صدّه لهجوم الفاطميين على مصر والدليميين في بلاد فارس.
يقول أحمد أمين في كتابه ظهر الإسلام؛
"وكانت الخلافة في أيام المقتدر مقسمة إلى ثلاث:
فالدواوين والكتابة في يد الفرس،
والخلافة والقضاء في يد العرب،
والجندية والعسكرية بيد الأتراك،
وهذه السلطات الثلاث تتعارض وتتآمر، وكل فرقة تدس لغيرها الدسائس..."
وفي نفس هذه السنة اي 308 هجري،
اندلعت انتفاضة في بغداد،
ضد الغلاء المشط لأسعار الخبز في عاصمة الخلافة،
بعد أن اقنع الوزير حامد بن العباس الخليفة المقتدر
بالمضاربة في مخزون القمح.
يقول الإمام الذهبي؛
"وفي سنة ثمان اي 308 هجري غلت الأسعار ببغداد،
وسغبت العامة لكون حامد بن العباس ضمن السواد،
وجدد المظالم،
ووقع النهب،
وركب الجند فيها وشتتهم العامة،
ودام القتال أياماً وأحرق العامة الحبس وفتحوا السجون
ونهبوا الناس ورجموا الوزير واختلفت أحوال الدولة العباسية جداً".
هذه الانتفاضة قادها الحنابلة،
و ساندها الحلاج من سجنه،
يقول لوي ماسينيون؛
" وهتف الثوار ضد الوزير حامد بن العباس في شوارع بغداد،
من أجل الاحتجاج ضد سياسته المالية، ومن أجل إنقاذ الحلاج معا."
حامد بن العباس سيقنع الخليفة المقتدر بالله
ان رأسي الفتنة هما الحنابلة و الحلاج.
المقتدر سيمنحه كل الصلاحيات لإخماد الانتفاضة ومحاكمة الحلاج.
ولمحاكمة الحلاج سيتم إستئناف النظر في قضية الحلاج الأولى،
وبإيعاز من حامد بن العباس سيصدر ابو بكر بن مجاهد،
وهو من أكبر القُرّاء واحد الرموز الدينية المؤثرة في بغداد،
فتوى مفادها ان عقيدة الحلاج تمس من وحدانية الذات الإلاهية.
سيأمر حامد بن العباس بوضع الحلاج في زنزانة انفرادية،
وتقييده بثلاثة عشر قيدا ومعاملته معاملة قاسية،
في الأثناء سيبعث الخليفة المقتدر بأحد رموز الأشاعرة،
وهو ابن خفيف ليجادل الحلاج  في السجن حول فساد معتقده،
يقول ماسينيون؛
"وكان ابن خفيف اشعريا متطرفا وعالما لا يثبت لجدله احد من الناس"،
ابن خفيف سينبهر انبهارا شديدا  بشخصية الحلاج،
ويرفض مغادرة غرفة سجن الحلاج،
يقول ابن كثير؛
"فحُمل بالقوة إلى حجرة أخرى، وعُلّق من قدميه إلى السقف..."،
إذن ابن خفيف الأشعري المتطرّف سيتحول إلى صوفي حلاجي.
سيعمل حامد بن العباس جاهدا على اقتلاع اجماع الفقهاء،
حول تكفير الحلاج،
ولكن شيخ الحنابلة ابن عطاء أبى ذلك،
فعندما سأله الوزير بن العباس عن معتقد الحلاج في مجلسه، قال له؛
"هذا اعتقاد صحيح، وأنا اعتقد هذا الإعتقاد، ومن لا يعتقد هذا فهو بلا اعتقاد"،
ثمّ توجّه له بكل شجاعة قائلا؛
عليك بما نُصبت له من أخذ أموال الناس،
وظلمهم وقتلهم، ما لك وبكلام هؤلاء السادة...
غضب الوزير حامد غضبا شديدا،
وأمر بضرب الشيخ الحنبلي ابن عطاء على رأسه حتى سال دمه،
ومات بن عطاء بعد أسبوع فقط متأثرا بجروحه.
يقول ابن الكثير في البداية والنهاية متحدّثا عن اهم الأحداث سنة 309 هجري؛
فيها وقع حريق كثير في نواحي بغداد بسبب زنديق قتل (يشير هنا إلى بن عطاء)،
فألقى من كان من جهته الحريق في أماكن كثيرة،
فهلك بسبب ذلك خلق كثير من الناس.
وفي جمادى الأولى منها قلد المقتدر مؤنسا الخادم بلاد مصر والشام،
ولقّبه المظفر وكتب بذلك في المراسلات إلى الآفاق .
وفيها قدم الوزير حامد بن العباس للخليفة بستانا بناه وسماه الناعورة،
قيمته مائة ألف دينار وفرش مساكنه بأنواع المفارش المفتخرة.
وفيها كان مقتل الحسين بن منصور الحلاج."
حَزِنَ الحلاج حزنا شديدا لمقتل صديقه بن العطاء،
وأحس ان مصيره سيكون مثله،
ولكنه لم يتزحزح قيد أنملة عن أفكاره ومواقفه،
وأصبحت له رغبة كبيرة في لقاء ربّه،
فكان يناجيه،
بهذه الكلمات،
والتي سوف تتكرر بلفظها ومعناها عند أبي فراس الحمداني،
وهو في الأسر يعاتب ابن عمه سيف الدولة،
وهناك من ينسبها كذلك إلى رابعة العدوية .
تقول الكلمات؛
تصاعد انفاسي اليك عتابُ
وكل إشاراتي اليك خطابُ
فَلَيتَكَ تَحلو وَالحَياةُ مَريرَةٌ
وَلَيتَكَ تَرضى وَالأَنامُ غِضابُ
وَلَيتَ الَّذي بَيني وَبَينَكَ عامِرٌ
وَبَيني وَبَينَ العالَمينَ خَرابُ
إِذا نِلتُ مِنكَ الوُدَّ فَالكُلُّ هَيِّنٌ
وَكُلُّ الَّذي فَوقَ التُرابِ تُرابِ
فَيا لَيتَ شُربي مِن وِدادِكَ صافِياً
وَشُربِيَ مِن ماءِ الفُراتِ سَرابُ...
استمعوا إلى هذه الكلمات بصوت الفنان أحمد حويلي؛
تصاعد انفاسي اليك عتابُ
هذا البيت الحلاج وصّى به أن يُقال لمن يعرف...
تصاعد انفاسي اليك
عتابُ
وكل إشاراتي
وكل إشاراتي اليك اليك خطابُ
فَلَيتَكَ تَحلو
وَالحَياةُ مَريرَةٌ
وَلَيتَكَ تَرضى
وَلَيتَكَ تَرضى وَالأَنامُ غِضابُ
وَلَيتَ الَّذي بَيني وَبَينَكَ عامِرٌ
وَبَيني وَبَينَ العالَمينَ خَرابُ
إِذ صحّ مِنكَ الوُدَّ فَالكُلُّ هَيِّنٌ
وَكُلُّ الَّذي فَوقَ التُرابِ تُرابِ
فَيا لَيتَ شُربي
مِن وِدادِكَ صافِياً
وَشُربِيَ مِن ماءِ الفُراتِ سَرابُ...
إذن ستتم محاكمة الحلاج الكبرى في قصر الخلافة،
وسيترأسها القاضي المالكي ابي عمر،
المعروف بتملّقه للسلاطين وأولي الأمر،
وستوجه للحلاج ثلاث تهم رئيسية وهي؛
المراسلة السرية مع القرامطة، اعتقاد اتباعه بالوهيته، وقوله انا الحق.
اعدّ الوزير حامد ابن العباس شهودا للقضية،
وسعى ان يكونوا من المقرّبين للحسين بن منصور الحلاج.
بدأت المحاكمة وجيء بالشاهد الأول ويدعى السمري، وكان من اتباع الحلاج،
في كتابه «تاريخ بغداد»،
يتحدث الخطيب البغدادي عن شهادة الشاهد الرئيسي في قضية الحلاج السمري،
ونفس هذه الشهادة يوردها لوي ماسينيون،
في كتابه آلام الحلاج في الصفحة 563 نقلا عن ابن الزنجي.
تقول الشهادة؛
"وأحضر حامدٌ، السمريَّ صاحبَ الحلَّاج،
وسأله عن أشياء من أمر الحلَّاج،
وقال له حدثني بما شاهدته منه.
فقال له: إن رأى الوزير أن يعفيني فعل!
فأعلمه أنه لا يعفيه،
وعاد وسأله عمَّا شاهده،
فعاود استعفاءه،
وألح عليه في السؤال، فلما تردد القول بينهما قال:
أعلم أني إن حدثتك كذبتني،
ولم آمن مكروهًا يلحقني،
فوعده أن لا يلحقه مكروهٌ،
فقال:
كنت معه بفارس، فخرجنا نريد إصطخر في زمنٍ شاتٍ،
فلما صرنا في بعض الطريق،
أعلمته بأني قد اشتهيت خيارًا،
فقال لي: في هذا المكان! وفي مثل هذا الوقت من الزمان؟
فقلت: هو شيءٌ عرض لي.
ولما كان بعد ساعاتٍ،
قال لي: أنت على تلك الشهوة؟ فقلت: نعم.
قال:
وسرنا إلى سفح جبل ثلجٍ،
فأدخل يده فيه، وأخرج إليَّ منه خيارةً خضراء ودفعها إليَّ!
فقال له حامد: فأكلتها؟
قال: نعم.
فقال له: كذبت يا ابن مائة ألف زانيةٍ، في مائة ألف زانيةٍ،
أوجعوا فكَّيه!
فأسرع الغلمان إليه، فامتثلوا ما أمرهم به،
وهو يصيح: أليس من هذا خِفنا!
إذن السمري الذي جيء به ليشهد ضد الحلاج،
شهادته كانت في صالح الحلاج وارهبت القضاة في المحكمة.
ثم جيء بالشاهد الثاني وهي بنت الشاهد الأول السمري،
وادعت إنها كانت في منزل الحلاج،
ودعتها ابنة الحلاج ان تسجد لوالدها،
فقالت؛ أو يسجد لغير الله؟
فأجابها الحلاج نعم إله في السماء، وإله في الأرض.
يُجمع كل المؤرخين تقريبا،
أن شهادة بنت السمري كانت باطلة،
وفعلت ذلك لأن حامد بن عباس هددها بالإنتقام من والدها،
اذا لم تقدم شهادة ضد الحلاج.
يقول ابن الزنجي؛
"وأقامت هذه المرأة معتقلة في دار حامد بن العباس إلى أن قتل الحلاج."
لم يقتنع القضاة بشهادة بنت السمري،
ورفضوا اصدار حكم يدين الحلاج  بناء على اقوالها.
وتوالت الايام،
وتوالت الشهور وتوالت الشهود،
وفي كل يوم يُجلب الحلاج من سجنه مقيدا بالسلاسل أمام القضاة لاستنطاقه،
ولكنهم عجزوا ان يجدوا له سقطة واحدة.
إذن تحولت محاكمة الحلاج إلى ملحمة روحية،
ووسعت من شعبيته وتعاطف الناس معه.
امر حامد ابن العباس بإحضار كل كتب ومراسلات الحلاج،
ليدقق فيها القضاة ليستخرجوا منها ما يُدين الحلاج.
إلى أن وجدوا في إحدى رسائل الحلاج،
أن الإنسان إذا تعذّر عليه الحج  إلى بيت الله الحرام،
يمكنه أن يطوف ببيته ثم يُطعم ثلاثين يتيما،
فإن ذلك يقوم له مقام الحج.
عندما سمع القاضي ابي عمر ذلك التفت إلى الحلاج وسأله:
"من أين لك هذا؟
فقال الحلاج: من كتاب الحسن البصري ‘الإخلاص‘،
فقال: كذبت يا حلال الدم"!!
وكانت تلك الكلمة القاتلة للحلاج،
فصاح حامد بن العباس بالقاضي وقال له:
"اكتب بهذا"! أي سجّله،
فأخذ القاضي يتمنّع ولكن حامد بن العباس ألحّ عليه بالكتابة،
ومد له الدواة ليسجّل ما نطق به،
فكتب القاضي ابو عمر بإحلال دمه،
وتبعه في ذلك بقية القضاة والفقهاء الحاضرين،
ورفض القاضي الحنفي ابن بهلول الموافقة على حكم بن عمر،
ولكن مساعده الأشناني وافق على الحكم.
وكان الحلاج يردد أمام القضاة؛
"ظهري حَمِي، ودمي حرامٌ،
وما يحل لكم أن تتأوَّلوا عليَّ،
واعتقادي الإسلام،
ومذهبي السنة،
وتفضيل أبي بكر وعمر وعثمان وعلي،
وطلحة والزبير،
وسعد وسعيد،
وعبد الرحمن بن عوف،
وأبي عبيدة الجراح،
ولي كتبٌ في السنة موجودةٌ في الوارقين،
فالله الله في دمي!
الغريب في الأمر،
أن الحلاج الذي أبيح دمه بتهمة إسقاط ركن الحج،
قد ادّى فريضة الحج ثلاث مرّات،
والأغرب ما ذكره المؤرخ الإصطخري عندما قال؛
انه لم يُعرَف للحسن البصري كتابٌ باسم الإخلاص،
ومع ذلك وضعت الرواية على لسان الحلَّاج اسم هذا الكتاب،
ووضعت على لسان القاضي أنه قرأه بمكة!!!
إذن الحسن البصري لم يؤلّف الكتاب
الذي إستند اليه القاضي ابي عمر لإحلال دم الحلاج.
كل الحساسيات المذهبية و الفكرية والسياسية وقتئذ،
من مالكية،
وشافعية،
وشيعة،
وحنفية،
وأشاعرة،
ومعتزلة،
وبعض المتصوفة.
تورطت في دم الحلاج باستثناء الحنابلة.
يقول لوي ماسينيون ان عدد الفقهاء والقرّاء من مختلف المذاهب،
الذين وافقوا على إدانة الحلاج بلغ أربعة وثمانين.
طلب الحلاج مقابلة الخليفة المقتدربالله وكان له ذلك،
دخل مجلس الخليفة مقيدا وكان مرفوع الرأس مشرق الوجه وقال له :
"أنا عبدٌ من عبيد الله،
مستسلمٌ لقضاء الله،
صابرٌ لحكم الله،
راضٍ بقضاء الله،
فافعل ما حُركتَ له،
واعمل بما استُعملت فيه،
وكن بعد ذلك شديد الحذر،
فيما تأتي به وتذر،
وانظر في عواقب أمرك،
وتأمل ما تأتيه بثاقب فهمك،
وصافي فكرك،
فإن رأيت الصلاح فيما قام في نفسك فأمضِ حكم عدلك.
وإني لا أعترض عليك ولا ألومك في فعلك،
ولكني أقول كما قال الخليل:
وَجَّهْتُ وَجْهِيَ لِلَّذِي فَطَرَ السَّمَاوَاتِ وَالْأَرْضَ حَنِيفًا وَمَا أَنَا مِنَ الْمُشْرِكِينَ.
المقتدر بالله،
تحت ضغط الوزير حامد وقائد الجيش مؤنس الخادم،
وافق على اعدام الحلاج ملقيا بتبعة دمه على القضاة.
في يوم الثلاثاء في الثالث والعشرين من ذي القعدة سنة تسع وثلامئة،
الموافق ليوم 26 مارس/ آذار سنة 922 ميلادية،
أُخرج الحلاج من زنزانته تحت حراسة مشددة،
وجيء به مقيدا بالاغلال إلى ساحة في قلب بغداد لتنفيذ حكم الصلب،
كان الحلاج شامخا جليلا،
وأمامه حشد عظيم اجتمع على ضفاف نهر دجلة،
وكان يردد؛
هَؤَلاءَ عِبَادُكَ،
قَدْ اجْتَمَعُوا لِقَتْلِى تَعَصُّباً لدِينكَ،
وتَقَرُّباً إليْكَ،
فاغْفرْ لَهُمْ !
فإنكَ لَوْ كَشَفْتَ لَهُمْ مَا كَشَفْتَ لِى،
لما فَعَلُوا ما فَعلُوا،
ولَوْ سَتَرْتَ عَنِّى مَا سَترْتَ عَنْهُمْ،
لما لَقِيتُ مَا لَقِيتُ،
فَلَكَ الحمدُ فِيما تَفْعَلُ
ولَكَ الحمدُ فيِما تُرِيدُ.
شدّ صاحب الشرطة الحلاج إلى آلة الصلب بعد أن لطمه لطمة هشمت أنفه،
وأمر الجلاّد بأن يضربه ألف سوط،
كان الحلاج صامدا لا يتأوه ولا يستعفي،
فقط كان يردد أحدٌ أحد.
ثم تقدم الجلاد بسيفه وقطع يده اليمني،
ثم يده اليسرى،
ولما اصفرّ وجهه لكثرة ما نزف من دمه،
مرر ذراعه النازفة على وجهه وخضّبه بالدم وقال مبتسما؛
"ركعتان في العشق لا يصح وضوؤهما إلاّ بالدم"،
ثمّ ردّد؛
أقتلوني يا ثُقاتي
إِنَّ في قَتلي حَياتي
وَمَماتي في حَياتي
وَحَياتي في مَماتي
أَنا عِندي مَحوُ ذاتي
مَن أَجَلَّ المَكرُماتِ
وَبَقائي في صِفاتي
مِن قَبيحِ السَيِّئاتِ
سَئِمَتْ روحي حَياتي
في الرُسومِ البالِياتِ
فَاِقتُلوني وَاِحرِقوني
بِعِظامي الفانِياتِ
ثُمَّ مُرّوا بِرُفاتي
في القُبورِ الدارِساتِ
تَجِدوا سِرَّ حَبيبي
في طَوايا الباقِياتِ.
استمعوا إلى هذه الأبيات بصوت الفنان أحمد حويلي؛
أقتلوني يا ثُقاتي
إِنَّ في قَتلي حَياتي
وَمَماتي في حَياتي
وَحَياتي في مَماتي
أَنا عِندي مَحوُ ذاتي
مَن أَجَلَّ المَكرُماتِ
وَبَقائي في صِفاتي
مِن قَبيحِ السَيِّئاتِ
سَئِمَتْ نفسي
سَئِمَتْ نفسي حَياتي
في الرُسومِ البالِياتِ
فَاِقتُلوني
وَاِحرِقوني
بِعِظامي الفانِياتِ
ثُمَّ مُرّوا
ثُمَّ مُرّوا بِرُفاتي
في القُبورِ الدارِساتِ
تَجِدوا
تَجِدوا سِرَّ حَبيبي
حَبيبي
في طَوايا الباقِياتِ.
أرجوكم أقتلوني
أقتلوني وَاِحرِقوني بِعِظامي الفانِياتِ
هذه الكلمات للحلاج ومشهد جلده وقطع يديه،
أثارت غضب الناس في ساحة الصلب،
فأسرع الجنود إلى بعض الفقهاء الحاضرين،
وأمروهم بأن يلعنوا الحلاج وينالوا منه أمام العامة.
ومضى اليوم وغربت الشمس،
وبات الحلاج مصلوبا مقطوع اليدين ودمائه تنزف،
ورابط اهل بغداد طوال الليل في ساحة الصلب.
وفي صباح اليوم الثاني قُطعت رجله اليمنى ثمّ اليسرى.
يقول الخطيب البغدادي:
«سمعت فارسًا يقول:
قُطعت أعضاء الحلَّاج، عضوًا عضوًا
وما تغير لونه، وما فتر لسانه عن ذكر الله.»
كان أعوان الوزير حامد يصيحون في الناس؛
أقتلوا الحلاج الزنديق وفي أعناقنا دمه،
ويجيؤون بشيوخ الصوفية والفقهاء لرجم جسد الحلاج الذي ينزف دما،
ومضى اليوم الثاني والليلة الثانية
والحلاج لازال حيا معلّقا على صليبه.
أسرع الحاجب نصرالقشوري ليخبر الخليفة بخطورة الوضع في بغداد،
ونصحه بأن يصدر أمرا بالعفو على جسد الحلاج الممزق
قبل أن تقوم ثورة على خلافته.
ولكن الوزير حامد رفض ذلك قائلا للخليفة؛
ان العفو عن الحلاج في هذه اللحظة سيشعل بغداد
أكثر مما يشعله قتله والتخلص منه نهائيا،
وصاح؛
اقتله يا أمير المؤمنين، وفي عنقي دمه،
اقتله وإن حدثت الثورة التي يتنبأ بها نصر فاقتلني،
اقتله قبل أن تثور العاصفة!
وخضع المقتدر لابن العباس،
وأمر بقطع رأس الحلاج وحرق جسده.
يقول ابن كثير؛
"فلما كان اليوم الثالث، تقدم حامد إلى الخشبة، فتلا أمر الخليفة،
ثم قرأ فتوى الفقهاء، بأن في قتل الحلَّاج صلاحَ أمر المسلمين!
ثم أمر الجلاد بقطع رأسه والإجهاز عليه."
ثم صُبّ على جسده النفط وأُحرق،
وحمل رماده على رأس منارةٍ ونُثر في نهر دجلة،
في السادس والعشرين من ذي القعدة، سنة تسع وثلاثمائة هجري
الموافق ل 26  مارس/اذار سنة 922 ميلادي،
وظلّ رأسه معلّقا يومين على الجسر ببغداد،
ثم طِيف به في خراسان،
ثم أخذته أم الخليفة المقتدر، فحنطته وعطرته،
وأبقته في خزانتها عامًا كاملا.
لم يكتف الوزير حامد والخليفة المقتدر بحرق جسد الحلاّج،
ولكن أمرا كذلك بحرق كتبه وأثاره،
ومنع تداول كل ما يشير إلى ذكراه عند الورّاقين.
لكن كلمة الفصل لم تكن لهما بل كانت للتاريخ،
فقتل الوزير حامد بن العباس بعد سنتين،
سنة 311 هجري أفظع قتلة وقُطعت يداه ورجلاه.
وقتل الخليفة المقتدر سنة 320 هجري على يد قائد الجيش مؤنس الخادم.
وقتل الخليفة القاهر بدروره قائد الجيش مؤنس التركي سنة 321 هجري.
وكل هؤلاء لا يذكرهم التاريخ،
إلا على هامشه عند حديثه عن الحسين بن منصور الحلاج،
الذي قطعت أفكاره قرونا من الزمن وامتدت ذكراه لأكثر من ألف عام،
ليعيد لها المستشرق الفرنسي لوي ماسينيون وهجها وبريقها
من خلال كتابه آلام الحلاج.
ادعوكم إلى الإطلاع على هذا الكتاب الهام للوي ماسينيون،
و احيطكم علما ان الجزء الأوّل قد ترجمه المترجم حسين الحلاج،
نعم يحمل نفس اسم الشهيد الحسين بن منصور الحلاج،
وصدر عن دار نينوى بدمشق.
كما أنصحكم بالإطلاع على كتاب الكاتب العراقي على بدر،
"ماسينيون في بغداد من الإهتداء الصوفي إلى الهداية الكولونيالية"،
وكذلك كتاب شخصيات قلقة في الإسلام للمفكر عبد الرحمان بدوي،
وكذلك كتاب الحلاج شهيد التصوف الإسلامي لصاحبه طه عبد الباقي سرور.
اشكركم جزيل الشكرعلى المتابعة،
ولا تنسوا الإشتراك بقناة انا أفكر إذن أنا موجود،
وتفعيل الجرس ليصلكم كل جديد،
...دمتم بخير وإلى لقاء قريب